located in the Cape Horn archipelago the
sub-antartic region of Chile is the
southernmost part of the Americas before
Antarctica itself
it's one of the very few untouched areas
on Earth with two percent land 98
pristine water and pre-industrial
Revolution air to breathe this is kind
of a Jurassic Park but a real Jurassic
Park that has survived the impact of
modernity so Chile offers to the world
this kind of natural Laboratories
scientists here are studying climate
change and global warming peat moss
captures more greenhouse gases than all
other vegetation combined so on this
enormous peat bog climate change expert
Frederick talaso has installed
sophisticated instruments that measure
how wind temperature ultraviolet light
among other factors impacted covariance
store gives us the total flux of CO2 or
methane that is emitted or captured by
the ecosystems that would allow us to
predict what could happen with the
peatlands in the future these dead trees
are the work of beavers who have no
natural predators in this part of the
world they swam here from neighboring
Southern Argentina where they were first
brought for the fur industry and where
they've already caused massive
destruction
satellite imagery reveals that there are
at least 36 000 beaver dams like the one
you see here on this Cape Horn Island
alone that deprives trees and plants of
oxygen which in turn rots the sediment
below and turns into methane emissions
of that greenhouse gas in this area have
increased by five to ten fold
what can be done
in the province's capital put it to
Williams we were invited to the
inaugural Global Conference of the Cape
Horn International Center or Chic it's
an ambitious initiative by the Chilean
government and the University of
magayanes to identify predict and
mitigate environmental changes
has just come back from installing a
meteorological station on remote Horn
Island that provides critical scientific
data via satellite in real time
Antarctica on its own is regulating the
global warming and climate changes that
we are witnessing so whatever happens
there will impact the entire world
without exception
if some researchers are right that this
sub-antartic region is a precursor of
what the South Pole May soon become
scientists will need all the information
they can get
Lucia Newman Al Jazeera navarino Island
Chile
foreign
[Music]